I worry about the future of the world I
worry about the nature of the world how
do you you've got a couple years on me
how do you where do you put where do you
put that in life it's just with you all
the time right this I knew at a very
early age the most cultured country in
the world built aitz there's this old
question how did the people who gave us
Beethoven and Bach give us aitz it's an
interesting question but it's it's
somewhat of a non seor why does having
Bach and Beethoven inoculate you against
being becoming evil the ease with which
civilization can turn morally that's
what Germany taught and I see that
happening in the United States